horse urine erectile Venom and even fish
sperm here are brief origin stories for
eight medications that may just shock
you did you know that some 18 million
Americans have diabetes and good
majority of those diabetics are type 2
where the body loses its ability to turn
blood sugar into energy because either
it doesn't produce enough insulin or
doesn't use it correctly type 2 diabetes
is often associated with obesity and can
potentially lead to serious health
complications like stroke amputation
kidney failure heart attacks heart
failure and so on now what if I told you
that one of the most successful ways to
control diabetes is from a shocking
component a lizard spit and I'll repeat
it again for the people in the back
lizard spit not just any lizard a large
venomous lizard found right here in the
United States and Mexico introducing the
Gila monster I know what you are
thinking there's no way this wild
looking reptile is treating chronic
health issues like diabetes oh contraire
my friends here's what's so cool about
it the gila monster's saliva contains a
very important 39 amino acid pep guide
called extending four this hormone is
almost exactly like a hormone that
humans produce called glucagon like
peptide one or glp-1 and it's given by
way of injection it works by stimulating
the pancreas to secrete insulin when the
blood sugar levels are high insulin
helps move sugar from the blood into
other body tissues where it is used for
energy so all in all it's wild to think
it all started with as a little cuddly
Gila monster
osteoarthritis have you ever seen a
rooster's comb it's the fleshy red
Mohawk looking growth on the top of the
rooster chicken or any gamefowl type of
bird's head wow roosters use this to
help cool themselves down we of the
human variety may have had a very
different use for this cold and it all
has to do with osteoarthritis
osteoarthritis is an inflammatory
disease that affects more than 30
million American adults on a very basic
level it's the the most common type of
arthritis that happens when joint
cartilage breaks down or is damaged it
can be very painful causing stiffness
and reduced function in your joints and
even a breakdown and changes the bone
underneath alright so how does one treat
this degenerative wear and tear type
arthritis there is a treatment that has
been around for decades it's called the
visco supplementation or hyaluronic acid
injections now you've probably seen
hyaluronic acid as an ingredient in skin
care or cosmetic products before but did
you know that your body actually
produces this clear gooey substance
naturally yes this helpful acid is
mostly found in your skin and connective
tissue and has multiple functions in the
body it helps your skin retain moisture
maintain flexibility and soothes dry
eyes helps in wound healing among many
other uses but circling back to the
earlier rooster combo cartilage from the
rooster Combs contain very high levels
of hyaluronic acid it can be given in a
series of injections to patients who are
suffering from osteoarthritis these
injections help help to not only
lubricate the joints but also decrease
their overall pain increased mobility
and even delays the need for joint
replacement surgery although hyaluronic
acid used to be extracted from the
cartilage of the rooster's comb
scientists have thankfully developed a
synthetic version that they now use to
treat patients hypertension it's been
called a potentially silent killer or at
least a precursor and a nearly half of
the U.S adults have this issue defined
as a systolic blood pressure greater
than 130 or a diastolic blood pressure
of greater than 80. if you're not sure
the numbers but are taking medication
prescribed by your doctor for
hypertension high blood pressure is very
concerning to Doc as it forces the heart
to work harder to pump the blood to the
rest of the body and damage one's
arteries by making them less elastic
potentially leading to heart disease
high blood pressure usually develops
over time and can happen because of
unhealthy Life Choices like not getting
enough physical activity or having other
health conditions such as diabetes and
obesity can also increase the risk of
developing high blood pressure
especially if it runs in your family
this could certainly put you at higher
risk what if I told you that another
potentially silent killer may just be
the treatment to set scary hypertension
meet the venomous Brazilian hararaka pit
viper that's right a medication derives
straight from this hair raising snake
but patients who have hypertension are
sometimes given a drug named captopril
captopril is an Ace inhibitor that was
developed in the 1980s H stands for
Angiotensin converting enzyme but simply
ACE inhibitors work by helping to relax
veins and arteries so the heart can pump
blood more efficiently and capture Pro
specifically was one of the first ACE
inhibitors and it was created using the
Venom from this deadly snake crazy right
on any other day one bite from a pit
viper like this can cause blistering
bleeding renal failure and even death
but now secured the right way this makes
Venom ore the synthetic form nowadays
truly contains the secret sauce to help
combat hypertension typically peptides
which are made up of strings of amino
acids and are essentially the building
blocks of protein these peptides found
in captopril act as an Ace inhibitor for
the folks with hypertension as I
mentioned before it has also been used
on other serious conditions like heart
failure kidney disease and is sometimes
given to patients who have suffered from
heart attacks you've probably heard of
antibodom right for instance you go
hiking and surprise you get bit by a
rattlesnake I often see these here in
Southern California where I work in the
emergency department people come into
the hospital needing a high dose of
Anti-Venom all that being said have you
ever wondered to yourself how exactly do
we get antimatter you may be surprised
to find out that it's not as cut and dry
as you may think to go back a few years
it was first developed in 1895 using
Venom from a cobra however the
anti-venom as we know it now was not
available until 1927. first off donor
animals usually horses sheep or even
goats are injected with a non-lethal
dose of Venom that animal's immune
system triggers a response and produce
this is antibodies these animals
typically have a robust immune system
and produce powerful antibodies that can
bind to the snake venom component from
there blood is then drawn from the
animal and the antibodies are separated
from the blood in the plasma the plasma
is concentrated and then purified into
high pharmaceutical grade antivenom
before being given to patients today
there are multiple anti-venom treatments
available for specific snakes and even
spiders but it's important to know that
not every hospital carries it so if you
find yourself bitten by a snake or other
venomous Critter make sure that you go
to the right medical facility that can
truly treat your wounds you don't want
to be wasting time when minutes and
hours could literally mean life and
death when it comes to combating a
venomous bite okay disclaimer this next
one is kind of a gross one but can be
necessary for some did you know that
there is a medication made from pregnant
horses urine this is true you see when
women begin menopause a period of time
that marks the end of their menstrual
cycles they have a low estrogen which
causes a variety symptoms including
changes in metabolism difficulty
sleeping mood changes and other problems
associated with this oftentimes to help
treat some of these issues a doctor will
prescribe estrogen to help boost their
levels and alleviate symptoms this is
called hormone replacement therapy now
one of these hormone replacement therapy
medications is known as Premarin it is a
highly prescribed orally administered
estrogen that is also available as a
topical cream and has been used since
1942 but here's the thing primarin comes
from Mare's urine and mare urine
contains high levels of estrogen and is
similar to the estrogen that humans
produce permanent does have some
controversy attached to it though some
ethical concerns have been raised due to
the treatment of the mirrors there have
also been some recent studies showing an
increased risk of cancer for patients
who were on Premarin but all that to say
hormone therapy is important for
patients that are actually suffering
from menopausal type symptoms this one
isn't exactly kosher but it's very
useful in treating patients that that
have trouble with their pancreas for
example if a patient is suffering from
chronic pancreatitis cystic fibrosis or
some sort of blockage between the
pancreas and the intestines they likely
do not have pancreatic enzymes that help
with digestion why is this a major deal
well not only does this affect how your
body breaks down food but the pancreas
also makes the hormones insulin and
glucagon that control your body's blood
sugar level and one in five cases of
severe pancreatitis can result in a
life-threatening complications like
multi-organ failure and could even
potentially be deadly here's the Silver
Line there is a medication to help with
this called pancrease pancre lipase
works by replacing the enzymes that your
pancreas is lacking and decreases fatty
bowel movement it also improves
nutrition by breaking down fats proteins
and starches into smaller substances
that can be absorbed in the intestine
but the million dollar question where
does this pancreas supporting medication
come from to be specific it comes from
the pancreas of pigs so whether you have
a religious aversion or if you have any
allergies to Pork you should probably
let your doctor know if you suffer from
any pancreatic issues if you need this
type of medication aspirin this is one
of the most common medications found in
almost every medicine cabinet on the
planet aspirin a non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drug very commonly
used to treat pain and swelling reduce
fever and so on it's also been used as a
blood thinner helping to prevent strokes
and heart attacks but you may not have
known about its oh so subtle Beginnings
around 3 500 years ago barked from a
willow tree was a traditional medicine
used by Sumerians Egyptians Greeks
Romans and more for pain relief fast
forward to the mid-1700s where an
English cleric by the name of Edward
Stone was investigating willow bark and
its effect on the sick he gathered some
willow bark and left it outside of a
Baker's oven for about three months and
once dried would grind it into a powder
he reported in a letter written to the
Royal Society that he gave the ground of
powder to 50 different people and with
the exception of a few chronically ill
patients that may have had malaria he
reported that all his patients
conditions improve it was later
discovered that the crystals isolated
from the Willowbrook could produce a
stronger compound called salicylic acid
among the many plant products that have
clinical utility salicylates and aspirin
are probably the most broadly used
estimates suggest that about a hundred
billion tablets are consumed each year
and are used to alleviate pain and other
issues number one weird places we derive
medications from has to go to a Heparin
reversal agent and finally we have
protamine this origin story of this
medication is certainly a bit fishy but
it may just save the life of you or
someone you love alright let me paint
the full picture here in a nutshell
Heparin is a medication used to prevent
blood clots from forming in people who
have certain medical conditions or who
are undergoing certain medical
procedures that increase the risks or
increase the chances that clots will
form for instance during open heart
surgery or or if you need dialysis
although it sounds super helpful and it
can be but sometimes excessive bleeding
can occur with anticoagulants or blood
thinners as they are commonly referred
to like Heparin this could be a major
issue so in order to stop the excessive
bleeding after say renal dialysis or
after open heart surgery a medication
called protamine sulfate is used to
counteract the anticoagulant or blood
thinning effect it acts as an antagonist
that neutralizes Heparin bleeding
complications great right well what if I
told you that the goods that make up
protamine were derived from salmon sperm
yes the swimmers of swimmers potentially
life-saving to the patients who require
a reversal of Heparin so long as you
don't have a fish allergy alright there
you have it weird places we get medicine
from shout out to nucleus medical media
for their awesome video library and
Graphics thank you so much for watching
and stay healthy my friends